you guys have turned the medical
reaction series into a total hit but I
wanted to take things to the next level
so I partnered with the folks from the
TV show the resident to give you a
behind-the-scenes look of the set
interview one of the main actors from
the show Manish Dayal and even tried my
hand at acting they offered me an Emmy I
was like chill for a second
[Music]
I'm here with Manish Dayal who plays dr.
Devin profession as a doctor gifted
doctor five stars do you ever have
difficulty onset there's a word you
don't know how do you all the time I
mean every script there these words I
often will look at the procedure or what
the word means on YouTube first and then
I have sort of visual there's one in
particular that really threw us less it
was an igloo yo feller I the Gloria
Fowler that's right what's your view or
how is your view changed of doctors now
playing the duct no I mean I've always
had great respect for doctors dedication
the commitment I have an even greater
respect for just the amount of knowledge
that doctors have to retain and exercise
every day it's its immense it's crazy
because on top of having to know even
your character right well researched
well studied Harvard knows a lot of
textbook information but then applying
in a practical sense to another human
being who's so complex that's such a
challenge that people normally don't
highlight there's a stage of being a
doctor in school and outside of the
hospital and then you see doctors inside
the hospital and what changes and how
they're applying textbook information
academics to practice and yes it can be
discombobulated especially for dividends
first yeah they get what is the first
question you ask you code we're on set
right now you have multiple sets here
you have the ER RoR do you mind giving
us a little tour so we can sort of
breakdown how realistic this is from a
medical solution no problem at all this
right here is the ER okay we have ten
trauma Bay's here this is the nurse's
station yep very accurate yeah yeah
what tell me about what this is well so
initially when I walked in here I was
really impressed with the attention to
detail like this is really cool to show
people at home the post-its are legit
are legit posted legit post legit impose
are covered in post-its these are the
urns work like what how come no no don't
look at these yeah patient privacy yeah
how do you do it don't violate HIPAA
right
yeah Hypno's yeah this is very accurate
the beds look like they're functional
the rails go up so this is yes so this
is very really a scene though dude so
basically figuring out how they lower it
and then it doesn't work yet this blood
pressure reading is a little crazy 91
over 132 so this patient what's wrong
with that patient this is just not this
is not a live person's blood pressure
the lower number yeah this person is
absolutely dead this is the ICU okay
this isn't very accurate as well is it
yeah the rooms need to be able to be
isolation rooms the way that they're
spread apart is very accurate the
nursing station being in the middle to
have the view of all the rooms is very
important this chart is actually really
realistic also because when the patient
is in the ICU they can develop something
known as delirium where they don't know
where they are and looking at this can
help them a lot they'll know who their
nurses who their doctor is it also is
helpful to some of the nurses taking
care of the patients to know what
they're supposed to be eating honestly
if I walked in here and I had no idea
where I was prior I would say I'm
definitely in a hospital there's no way
I would say that this is a set now we're
gonna move tiny or let's move it which
is where all the blood and the guts
which was the first scene of the entire
show
all right that's when that's where else
yeah I got chills during that part
really cuz I I've seen medical errors
happen in front of me maybe not to that
extent but I remember it brought up all
these feelings of what I felt during
those moments right it made you feel as
if you were there so this is a young
doctor when you have you know when the
responsibility to your job but also your
your bosses and the people autumn can
for you Wow this
see you room I mean there's so much
blood on this floor usually heck you
wouldn't even be able to walk we have
this machine the blood splatter machine
okay there's a pump that looks like a
helium pump okay and attached to it is a
clear tube that gets hidden under the
clothing or you know take behind the arm
of the patient so when it's time for the
blood to squirt they pump it and the
blood just squirts out and usually my
characters behind that glass just
watching yeah because you're not a
surgical matter I wish you wrote you do
rotate right so we do rotate I mean
right now I'm in the ER and if I'm lucky
I'll get to move to surgery okay this is
another Wow so in the next episode which
we start shooting on Monday
it's the Halloween episode okay and
everyone is tasked with a different job
but there's this big Halloween party so
the doctors all go to the Halloween
party and my character is left in the ER
to treat this arm that comes in these
lights are legitimate you see like this
little covering on the light is to make
sure that even when you touch it you
still maintain your sterility
so sunshine is the one that generally
gives you the guidance yeah how often is
she saying guys you have to stop this
and stop the scene because the technique
is wrong here does that happen almost
you won't stop it while we're while
we're taking she'll wait until we call
cut data to come in with a note and
we'll implement it and then shoot it
again awesome yes because there's always
pieces they can take how many cameras
are going at the rates and sometimes we
cornice Wow we watch them film a scene
for season two not gonna spill any
secrets but it's incredible how many
things are happening simultaneously
there's multiple cameras moving around
actors actresses extras it blew my mind
how much needs to happen in order for
one scene to get taken in the perfect
way who is this just is let's see here I
have no clue and then this is sort of
the view this is it yeah we're where
there's a scene in the first
we're all viewing a very complicated
surgery you know if you're an internist
or someone not allowed in there you use
medical students and I can come in here
so medical students at home this is
where you'd be hanging out watching the
operation go line up the signs are
accurate in terms of which way to go
they're complicated just like there are
in real life after getting the tour of
the entire set I really wanted a know
firsthand what it would be like to be an
actor on a medical drum Manish was kind
enough to do a little improv session
with me I am dr. profession that's your
name hi doctor what took so long I don't
understand I've been here for an hour
I'm sorry you see all these patients we
ask a breeze into the yard my stomach's
been killing me doc okay I don't want to
be frank here but my stool it's
disgusting Wow how long have you had
these since like 24 hours I came back
from Mexico I don't know if it's Zika
what what am I doing here doc what is
this like it's tumor is it no it's not
it will we'll get to the bottom of that
oh my stomach I'd like your stethoscope
by the well thank you that black it's a
great choice it is yeah they they
sponsor my practice doctor why are you
listening to my lungs what I told you
you see I can't act I'm sorry I'm gonna
stick to being a doctor
I'm Manish we appreciate you taking out
the time we're going us behind the
scenes allowing me to show off my
horrible acting chops what grade do you
give me I give you a solid eight Wow
yeah that's too kind he's an obviously
lying but again thank you for the time
everyone check out the season premiere
of season 2 of their resident stay happy
and healthy
[Music]